[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
got their first historic Glimpse at the
queens of Nashville
the world of country music was Far
different than it is today
I think you've got the bore a hole
through the potato long way now we use a
5 8 inch bit we use
a we use the 3
fitted I have to get more Pig in your
teeth yeah
and you hold the Tater real real real
partner and then you kind of take it
right here in the middle
today country music isn't male dominated
nor is it just confined to the hills and
small towns of America
the music is a large part of
contemporary society and everyone seems
to want a piece of it what sets these
ladies apart from the rest of the pack
is their passion for music they have
been singing since childhood and now are
the standard by which country music is
judged
I think country music has the same
appeal that rock and roll music has I
think it's feel good I can relate to
this music
unlike Rock and Roll country music
focuses more on lyrics more On Emotion
as opposed to just creating pure
adrenaline but I think there are a lot
of artists in recent history that have
really channeled into that upping the
ante upping the energy level of country
music and it's really become noticeable
I mean you used to go to a country
concert and it was a band up there
playing now it's like a rock and roll
spectacle but with lyrical stimulation
with songs that you can sing along to
and with that same country familiarity
that makes us feel really really
comfortable
in 1947 Bob McCoy and Ernest Tubbs
performed at Carnegie Hall to a cheering
overflowing crowd that proved the
doubters wrong in 1955 Marty Robbins
took it a step further with his
television performances my name is
Charlie Applewhite and welcome once
again to country style USA brought to
you by your local United States Army
recruiter and this television station
country style USA features the best in
country and western music and your
favorite Stars will be here for your
viewing and listening pleasure and now
here he is the star of our show Columbia
recording star Marty Robbins
I'd like to find somebody who could be
just halfway through but I can't quit
I've gone too far I'm deep in love with
you
I'd like full of steaks and leave that's
what I'd like to do but I can't quit
I've gone too far and even though
if I knew then what I know now I
wouldn't be smooth
I agree seeing you long ago
in the 21st century Faith Reba Miranda
Carrie and Taylor are selling out
stadiums worldwide to cheering fans
because they are indeed the queens of
Nashville it's like being on a stage
with the best Role Models I could ask
for just in terms of dignity and Grace
and longevity in their careers and these
people have written songs about their
life honestly and from an authentic
place and I think that's the definition
of country music
[Music]
thank you
at an early age Taylor Swift knew she
wanted to sing like Faith Hill Shania
Twain and the Dixie Chicks
shining glittery thing to me I'm so
excited about
the opportunity to possibly walk away
with a Grammy you know I don't know what
that feels like I've never gotten up
there and accepted a Grammy before and I
don't know someday I'd really like to
know what that feels like
it didn't take long for the driven young
lady to make her way to Nashville where
she went on to win seven Grammy Awards
11 American Music Awards seven country
Association awards six Academy of
Country Music Awards and four Billboard
Music Awards as a songwriter the
Nashville songwriters Association and
the songwriters Hall of Fame have
honored her
it's the best senior year I can imagine
well for this award I I guess I saw my
name on the ballot but didn't really
think that I had a chance at winning and
you know I I was like yes it's good to
be a nominee but I honestly didn't think
that I was going to win this award and I
can't believe that I did I can't believe
that the fans did that for me everybody
on MySpace they're the reason why I am
holding this award right now Taylor
Swift America's sweetheart was born
December 13 1989 in Reading Pennsylvania
at nine years old Taylor and her family
moved to Wyomissing Pennsylvania there
she spent her summer vacations at her
parents beachfront home in Stone Harbor
New Jersey
I'd say they made a pretty big sacrifice
um when she was 14 her father up and
moved the whole family to Hendersonville
Tennessee
fortunate for him he was able to
transfer to the Merrill Lynch office in
Nashville
well I have family that I spend every
Thanksgiving with they're all on my
mom's side and they're all women and
they're really loud they're obnoxiously
loud and they all have this genetic
cackle it's and they stand in the
kitchen and it's the loudest sound it
like breaks noise barriers and it's like
it's like out of a movie I mean my
cousins have like 49 cats and dogs and
it's it's really fun to go there and
have somewhere I know I'm going to be
every Thanksgiving
at the same time Swift became interested
in singing and often went to New York
for vocal lessons before long she had
become consumed with country music to
hone her skills she used all of her free
time to perform at all kinds of events
from Boy Scout meetings and sporting
events to local festivals and coffee
houses at the beginning of the year I'm
going to the UK again and doing a tour
there I'm going to Australia and I'm
going to Japan so I'm really excited
about that and then when I get back I'm
starting my headlining tour in May and I
just I can't wait after watching Faith
Hill on Behind the Music the young
artist knew she was destined for
Nashville
she just had to figure out a way to be
different so she would stand out from
the noisy Nashville Music crowd Taylor
knew her strength would be writing her
own songs
to me Taylor Swift is sheer Brilliance
you know she uh
writes feelings from you know past life
experiences and I think
everybody but young young girls in
general you know all over the world can
relate to that
thank you
[Music]
I think Taylor's just wise Beyond her
years you know she knew exactly what she
wanted and she had a Clear Vision of
what teenagers wanted to hear musically
you know she also was super dedicated in
trying to capture her own teenage years
through her music
sometimes I don't even know how I feel
until I write it in a song and I feel
very lucky to have been able to write
all the songs that I've ever recorded
and especially with this new album
writing them all you know without any
co-writers I am very excited for people
to hear it night one time I gave her an
award on one of the shows and she was
one of the both those two or two of my
children I got eight the two of them are
real Taylor Swift fans yeah and they're
just so excited here that I'll be up
here
just a little bit bad she was very nice
I think for me I just live on the hope
that if I keep on writing about my life
and my life is constantly changing my
music will also be changing as well at
15 Taylor left RCA records she was ready
to start recording her album but her
parents wanted her to wait a few years
to split from her record label and
manager
you know before Swift
the record industry had no idea that
there was a huge audience of young girls
who love country music
country music that talked about teenage
problems and life in general and it's a
success in 2005 at an industry showcase
at Nashville's Bluebird Cafe Swift
caught the attention of Scott borchetta
of big machine Records who signed her to
a record deal Swift immediately got work
she wrote three of the album songs
including two singles and co-wrote the
other eight with various artists the
final product was released in 2006 her
self-titled debut album Taylor Swift for
me performing innocent on the VMAs was a
great way to put a lot of it behind me
and I'm very happy about that I was very
grateful that I was given the
opportunity to perform a song that
nobody had heard before and really happy
with the responses that I got back to
the song that was wonderful
with the success of her debut album
Swift promoted the lp extensively in
addition to her own material Swift
played covers of songs by Beyonce
Leonard Skynyrd Eminem and Rihanna
people have influenced her including her
grandmother
Marjorie Finley who was an opera singer
so right there it shows you a lot about
um Range
you know people think these they're just
keyed into one thing but sometimes it's
opera or um choir or
classical or it could be a million
things
genres that fit into the genre that we
know them as
also she said on medications that Shania
Twain
who is you know the sort of the queen
bee but anyway Shania Twain was not only
as a songwriter but also as a performer
was her biggest musical influence I am
performing it's just wonderful to be
here because there's many people that I
respect
to detection and detecting it early and
there's that you know these people that
I've looked up to for so long getting to
meet people like Tom Hanks and then on
the other and I get to play music so
it's wonderful to be here tonight
in 2008 Swift released her second studio
album Fearless it debuted at number one
on the billboard 200 selling more than
8.6 million copies worldwide
[Applause]
in 2010 Taylor Swift's Speak Now album
solidified her as one of the best
songwriters in country music that album
sold more than 6 million copies and the
tour was attended by over 1.6 million
fans grossing over 123 million dollars
despite all of her accomplishments her
most famous moment was the infamous
clash between herself and rapper
producer Kanye West
said something like Beyonce's video
should have won at that time I kind of
felt bad for Taylor she looked like a
deer in headlights I kind of wish she
hadn't gone as far as he did but what
are you gonna do I thought it was
hilarious because I love Kanye I was
just like
at first I was surprised and then I
started laughing I was just like oh man
but I didn't think it was like
I mean I can see if it was me except me
to a reward I probably have been like
but overall I just kind of laughed just
kind of outside looking in type thing
I'm a huge fan of Beyonce as well you
know I actually if it's jumping off
topic you know in that direction I favor
Beyonce more so you know so it's an
honest opinion you know I definitely I
think that was out of out of hand
definitely because you should be able to
respect artists in any genre especially
when you've got Taylor Swift at what is
she 19 20 something like that with you
know the range of success you know that
she's covered in a matter of four years
you know it took Beyonce how long to get
to that stuff like that spot you know
platinum records millions and millions
of copies of every single that she's
released and I think that was definitely
just stepping out of hand and you know
part of me thinks that you know Kanye's
side of that was a little bit of
jealousy you know but either way it was
overstepping a huge line
at 23 Swift already has a lifetime of
achievements although she's known for
her narrative songs about her personal
experiences she has also proven to be a
great actress as well now that she's
worth over 165 million dollars what's
next for Taylor
looks like the sky is the limit
you know
see see your hero and and get
inspiration from All Your Heroes but try
to be something completely different
from your Heroes you know for me I think
that
um you know writing my own songs was a
way to to you know create what I wanted
to create and music about my life and
that way it kind of became just a diary
put to music every time I put out a new
record and um and I guess I guess I
would say learn an instrument because it
just makes everything easier like if
you're gonna go play out like it just it
helps if you've got your own guitar and
you can go accompany yourself
[Music]
thank you
in Faith Hill's 19-year career she has
sold over 40 million records worldwide
had 13 number one singles and 20 number
one videos
Has there ever
been a more exciting female artist of
Faith Hill I mean
the hits
this image of beautiful wife loving
mother
Tim McGraw right by her side the fact
that she clawed her way up through the
music industry never let go of her
dreams that's exactly what you want in a
country music Superstar she's it she's
all of it and on top of it she's one of
the most beautiful women in the world
Faith Hill is the first female artist to
have not one not two but three
consecutive number one albums on both
the country and the pop charts
think about that and she did it at a
time when country and pop were just
starting to come together she's one of
the ones that that kind of blurred the
line Kenny Chesney Shania Twain all of
them have obviously pretty much just
erased the line but this point by this
point but Faith was the one that got pop
listeners to say hey I like this
she may be country but I like this a lot
Hill is the only female artist in
history to have three consecutive albums
debut at number one on Billboard's pop
and country charts
one of the biggest country stars of the
90s and the 2000s was Faith Hill she
took full advantage of the inroads at
Shania Twain had made crossing over into
the pop music side of things and she
actually capitalized with some country
songs that actually had crossed over and
became pop Sensations so subsequently
she had some very huge tours and she was
one of the biggest stars that the
country music scene has seen in a long
time
but this queen of Nashville did not stop
there the Grammy Awards The Academy of
Country Music the Country Music
Association the American Music Awards
and the People's Choice Awards have also
honored faith in 2001 Faith was named
one of the 30 most powerful women in
America by the Ladies Home Journal in
2009 billboard named her the number one
adult contemporary artist of the decade
I tell you what there there aren't too
many artists that would have the
confidence to go as commercial as Faith
Hill has I mean think about it there
hasn't been a magazine cover I don't
think that she hasn't appeared on she's
been a cover girl for Revlon she has
fragrances you name it and she's got her
perfectly manicured hands in it Audrey
Faith Perry AKA Faith Hill was born on
September 21st 1967 in Ridgeland
Mississippi
she began performing at age seven she
had a defining moment at age nine when
she had the fortune of attending an
Elvis Presley concert which inspired her
to become a performer not long after
arriving in Nashville Faith auditioned
to be a backup singer for Reba McIntyre
unfortunately she didn't get the gig
instead she went to work at a music
publishing firm as a receptionist well
if you want to be great you have to
immerse yourself in the music and the
culture
um of the city and it is an electrifying
City and that's it just draws it's like
a magnet for great singers
for anybody that's been to Nashville
Tennessee there is nothing
like walking down Broadway 10 o'clock at
night
past one bar after another each bar
filled with people and on the stage and
the stages are usually right in the
corner right by the front door
always a band plan
and the bands in Nashville just seem to
have heart
they seem to have
just a genuine love for the music
they're playing and a lot of the music
they're playing is their own their own
lyrics their own music their own works
of art and you feel that in Nashville I
think that's what makes the city so so
magical so special so legendary when it
comes to music and and another great
thing I love about walking down Broadway
is that the people that you hear from
the street
are the people that are going to be just
a few blocks over at the Ryman
Auditorium and
you know that's just the way Nashville
Works Nashville takes care of its own
Nashville makes dreams come true it
always has it always will
it's the heart of country music
eventually Faith did land a job with her
Idol Reba McIntyre but it wasn't to sing
instead it was a gig packing fan club
merchandise
no doubt about it if you want to make it
as a country singer you have to go where
all the action is and that's Nashville
music publishing executive Daniel Hill
married 20 year old faith on July 23
1988 after dating for more than a year
even though she was married Faye still
dreamed of a career in country music
well Daniel hill was a Nashville
record executive and I believe
specifically he was in music publishing
pretty clear that Danny felt Faith had
her doubts
marriage is difficult for any average
couple you know but throw into the mix
face obviously climbing career and you
know fill in the blank
[Music]
as fate would have it a co-worker heard
her singing one day and encouraged her
to become a demo singer you've got to go
to got to have singing lessons you know
train your voice
um you know personally I don't think
it's all about having natural Talent you
know there are millions of people out
there with natural talent that can sing
but you got to bring your own flavor to
the mix you know a new sound a new look
you know you can't just copycat your
favorite artists you won't make it
Hill decided to kick her career up a
couple of notches by singing back up to
various artists
Faith was eventually discovered by an
executive at Warner Brothers he was so
impressed with her strong vocal
abilities that he immediately signed her
to a record deal
the good news was bittersweet just
shortly after the greatest achievement
in her career Faye's personal life took
a hit as she filed for divorce in 1994.
you know how to give her ex-husband
credit you know he says he's not bitter
and he's really proud of her success
[Music]
Faith rebounded from her divorce and her
music career began to soar her first two
albums each sold over 3 million copies
in 1996 Faith began touring with fellow
country singer Tim McGraw although Faith
was engaged to Scott Hendricks at the
time McGraw and Hill had an immediate
attraction to one another and began a
steamy love affair
I think the phrase is there for a reason
you know Opposites attract
Tim's more of the guy you know roll out
of bed throw on a T-shirt and jeans and
goes about his day in front of thousands
and thousands of people and you know
faith is over here you know she's
a little more outgoing you know more of
flashy Fireside you know so I think
that's one of the many reasons you know
they keep their marriage healthy and get
along so well
Tim McGraw and Faith Hill married on
October 6 1996. soon after they started
a family and had three children
despite their busy lives both insist on
spending quality time together as a
family
Faith Hill and Tim McGraw have been
together since 1996 and they've had to
make it work it's difficult to do that
Within the Music Industry yeah there's
many stories of
Showbiz couples that have gone separate
directions but they've made it work and
one way they've done it or at least
they've admitted to doing this is going
on date nights to sort of remove
themselves from all the glitz and glamor
and sometimes the Troubles of being in
under the scrutiny of the Showbiz lights
and even Tim McGraw years ago quit
drinking so he could focus on the family
and those things among others allowed
their relationship to get closer and has
allowed them to be affordable Duo
they're a strong team and
and they're two of the biggest country
acts the world's ever seen
you have four girls in the house tough
job
I mean to it's always Valentine's Day
with you baby oh
gosh I don't know we've done
it's pretty simple to be honest with you
we nothing really freaking crazy no we I
mean we like you know our best times are
just to hang out the house with the kids
you know that's what we try to do at
some point I mean every now and then
we'll go on a date but our date nights
are usually during the afternoon 12
o'clock in the afternoon having lunch on
a Tuesday and going to a movie yeah one
of the best rules they have in my
opinion is that they have a rule where
they are adamant about not being apart
from each other for more than three days
at a time
now that's a good rule you know because
I think
um
you know it's it helps you from straying
when you're on the road you know it
could be all alone and um you could have
a lot of fans adoring fans who love you
and so if if you if you make sure you're
you're together a lot it helps you know
yeah you've actually we went to see Rod
Stewart one year when he came through
Nashville and
um I remember he was going into his
Encore and he was just about seeing hot
legs and you pulled me out of the out of
the seat and I was like what are you
doing I have to see what Rod Stewart
seeing hot legs in and you then you
blindfolded me and put me into the car
went to the airport got on a plane we
were gone and we're gone and I forgave
you once we got to where we're going
in 1998 he'll release Faith a pop
country hit that sold more than 6
million copies she immediately followed
that up with another CD titled breathe
which sold 10 million copies and
garnered her three Grammy Awards
first of all I heard that she changes
diapers right before she even goes on
the stage you know which is
amazing because but you know she's
dedicated to that balance
um you know she's dedicated to making
um to making her family situation work
while enjoying her career at the same
time
and
um it looks like
she has hit her stride and
you know making it all work
in 2000 fade found her career in high
gear being featured in television
commercials performing at award shows
becoming a cover girl and winning the
CMA female vocalist of the Year award
collectively they've sold 70 million
albums
won eight Grammy Awards
14 Country Music Awards
14 American Music Awards
seven People's Choice Awards and 26
Academy of Country Music Awards please
join me in welcoming Tim McGraw and
Faith Hill
thank you
[Applause]
thank you so much John that was quite an
introduction thank you
I'm so excited
um this is thrilling for us
um
to be a part of this extraordinary
experience
for this limited time the Venetian has
just offered
um
there opened the doors here and welcomed
us
in such a gracious way and
we're creating a show that is going to
be uh remarkable for our fans but as I'm
here today and backstage and we're
preparing to come out I feel like it's
going to be one of the most remarkable
experiences for us as well um
we're truly excited and thank you so
much for being here
Faith Hill along with her husband Tim
McGraw has been on a world trotting
Whirlwind worldwide tour and the the
soul to soul tour has been one of the
biggest in country music history
you can see us in you know Arenas and
stadiums and outdoor venues and all that
stuff just for us we wanted to do
something really cool in here and it's
been just as cool for us as hopefully
it's been for the audience never really
has it's been fun
over the next few years Faith kept up
her frantic Pace by releasing the CD cry
in 2002 which sold more than 4 million
albums worldwide in 2006 faith and her
husband Tim McGraw began the soul to
soul tour the tour became the highest
grossing Country Music Tour Ever with a
gross of 90 million in 2007 Faith Hill
took over as the voice of the NFL on
NBC's Sunday Night Football by singing
the theme song on February 1st 2009 Hill
performed America the Beautiful at the
Super Bowl 43 pregame show ABC TV has
long had Monday Night Football and Hank
Williams Jr famously
saying a intro song for Monday Night
Football but when NBC television took on
Sunday Night Football they wanted to
come with somebody just as formidable
and just as recognizable as Hank
Williams Jr and they did with Faith Hill
you watch football all day on a Sunday
and Saturday she does yeah she doesn't
she'll even watch it with me on occasion
so yeah she likes football too you find
a woman like that I'm very lucky
any advice for many out there looking
for a football loving misses yeah stay
away from mine on September 17 2012 hell
debuted the song illusion at the CMA
Music Festival
despite her very busy life Faith has
still managed to have an acting career
release fragrances as well as give of
her time and money to charity
organizations
but Faith Hill clearly
also has heart
she's very active in several different
charities and she doesn't preach it she
doesn't sell that she doesn't say look
at all the good I do in the world she
just does it
and that speaks volumes
I think because of you know cancer has
touched everyone's life and that's in
particular I remember my father died of
cancer and my mother had cancer at an
early age when I was very young and
survived and I I grew up with a house
full of women my mom my two sisters and
I live in a house full of women now with
my wife and my three daughters and
awareness early detection all those
things are very important to us and
um you know we're we're a lot of people
do a lot more work than we do but we're
lucky that we have a position that we
have a Podium that we can put a face on
it and uh bring attention to it and
that's what we're here to do and that's
what it's all about for a celebrity I
guess in a position that we're in to get
these comments
the first joint award
s that's non-music related yes
yeah well well it's we because we've
gone through this together as a family
and it was difficult to uh to get the
news of tug and it was difficult to
watch him fight you know for the last
six months of his life uh so from that
came a great deal of knowledge and and
dedication
towards cancer cancer research quality
of life we do that together so anything
you can do together it's good even
though faith has reached Mega stardom
she's still the Girl Next Door ambitious
and driven as ever one of the things I
write about
in my books is finding that
family work balance
it is so hard to do that
which is why it's so admirable and so
rewarding when we see people who have
achieved that balance because let's be
honest when you're chasing your dreams
regardless of how big or small they may
seem
there are a lot of things that get
pushed to the side
and to make sure that your family is not
one of those things that gets pushed to
the side is a real accomplishment and a
real
Medal of Honor for people that can do
that faith has managed
to achieve incredible success doing what
she always wanted to do but even more
importantly achieve success as a mother
and a wife
and when it all comes down to it when
When the Crowds have left the concert
venue when people stop downloading your
music when nobody's going to see the
movies or the TV shows that you're in
what matters
is your kids what matters is your family
and what matters is love and to know
that you've never abandoned that that
you've never put that second in your
life
is the greatest success story a person
could ask for oh and she better be there
oh me yeah oh he's gonna have to let me
do something maybe I'll bring out his
microphone or yeah right or your guitar
or you can give me your guitar you've
never I've never gotten one of your
guitars that would be fun
you kept my guitar all the time
riebenil McIntyre was born on March 28
1955 in Kiowa Oklahoma to the parents of
Jacqueline and Clark McIntyre Reba began
her career while still a teenager
singing in her High School band and a
local radio
she was heavily influenced by the
country music of Bob Willis Merle
Haggard Dolly Parton Barbara Mandrell
and Patsy Cline
the quintessential success story
in country music is Reba McIntyre
you can see and you can hear and you can
feel
the influences of some of the greats of
Loretta Lynn of Barbara Mandrell the
grit of Merle Haggard the down home
dirt on your feet banjo on the front
porch mama with the Fiddle country music
that is still a thread in Reba's voice
and in her music today she is classic
country and
I think a lot of people forget that I
think a lot of people
forget that Reba's been around since the
70s I mean we can't even begin to count
on all of our toes and fingers the
number of hits she's had the year she's
been with us same could be said for
people like George Straits you know I
had this conversation the other day
about uh you know they're like well
George Strait put out a a double CD 50
number one hits that was 10 years ago
that that came out there have been more
same with Reba everything she does goes
right to the top because people love the
classics
I've seen Reba McEntire on the red
carpet and she is absolutely classy one
of those women when you walk up and you
look at you and it's like oh man I wish
she was my mother she's just brilliant
in so many ways she has a wonderful
voice but on the red carpet she keeps it
simple and she makes it like your your
her neighbor so she's like hi y'all
what's up hi and that friendliness is
really what makes it special
McIntyre knew the music business inside
and out while with Mercury records she
released six albums before signing with
MCA
Reba McIntyre was the most successful
country singer in the 80s and 90s
so she expanded on that popularity and
went to different Avenues she had her
own television sitcom
and she proved that through that
diversification I mean she's really gone
past what is the country music world
she's the biggest crossover country star
since Dolly Parton
all of the acts that are out there today
these uh extremely talented young women
who have obviously been very successful
in music
obviously know how to tour know how to
put on a show
all of them look up to Reba McIntyre
because Reba has done it all and more
importantly she's done it all well
and I think that that is a quality that
any young person should look up to I'm a
big believer
in modeling
and finding someone who is doing what
you want to do and doing it very well
Reba McEntire defines that this time
Reba decided to take creative control
and do things her way no more country
pop she was going to sing hardcore
country
well Reba McIntyre is is is hit funny
cool
um you know anyone who's watched her
show is just you know she's just
adorable and
um she already was just a huge country
singer and she had nothing to prove she
decided you know why not
and
she's just a talent and it's obvious
a lot of that style some of the
phrasings the Cadence in some of those
country songs and uh and was able to
sort of uh sort of springboard her
career from that a lot of country songs
tell a story and there's a there's a
first verse that sort of sets up what
the initial story is in a second verse
that takes it one step further in the
third verses is the big overall picture
of what the song is all about and uh you
know it's sort of like the structure of
a of a good story and a structure of a
good country song and uh Reba was more
than familiar with that
although Reba had been married before to
Charlie battles and divorce in 1987. she
decided to give love another chance by
tying the knot with novel Blackstock on
June 3rd 1989. on February 23rd 1990
Reba gave birth to their son Shelby
McIntyre Blackstock after 24 years of
marriage and still going strong Reba
said the secret to their wedded bliss
was having respect Faith love trust and
lots of patience
Reba McEntire's fan base consists of the
most loyal and devoted people
I've ever
seen in person in 2005 I was performing
in Shreveport Louisiana
Reba was giving a concert that night an
outdoor concert and they asked me to
introduce Reba on stage
I walked on stage
and there were people lined up against
the railing for her show that had been
there now keep in mind it's nine o'clock
at night
these people had been there since nine
o'clock that morning just to be close to
Reba now you say that's common every
concert has fans that have been there
all day these were the people that were
up front
the wave of devoted fans who had waited
12 hours to see her went back almost as
far as the eye could see over 7 000
people lined up in a parking lot in the
middle of summer in Shreveport Louisiana
just to be close to Reba that says a lot
Reba was living a Charmed Life until
tragedy struck on March 16 1991.
Reba just got finished performing at IBM
for a bunch of Executives just outside
of San Diego
uh very next day members of her band and
the pilot all died in a plane crash
Reba dedicated her 16th album for my
broken heart to her tour manager and Her
Seven band members that passed away and
it just must have been a real tough time
for her
Reba McIntyre's traveling band her
touring band
perished in a plane crash and
um
it greatly affected Reba after that she
subsequently
took a little break did write
significantly during that time or at
least soon thereafter and released an
album
that very much delved into those
personal relationships that she'd had
you know the the connection between
an artist and their touring band is
usually very close they're on the road a
great deal they spend a lot of time
together they Forge very strong
relationships and
Reba was very close with a lot of good
friends that had passed away in that
plane crash with her music career
soaring McIntyre became interested in
acting she co-hosted on Good Morning
America and in 1990 she landed her first
film role playing Heather Gummer in the
horror comedy Tremors starring Kevin
Bacon because
the acting side of her career
by any definition in Show Business
is beyond successful she had a sitcom
from uh 2001 to 2007 a six-year run for
a sitcom that puts it right up there
with some of the grades right and and
for many people that's the only Reba
they know the Reba from the Reba sitcom
but let's go back to the very beginning
sheet you want to play a little six
degrees here her first major acting role
was in a movie called Tremors alongside
Kevin Bacon
you know if you're going to start off
with somebody might as well start off
with one of the best so her career was
destined to be great from the very
beginning
in 1996 director James Cameron Cass riba
as Molly Brown in his Epic film Titanic
but when production extended Beyond its
original length Reba had to turn down
the part the role was recast with Kathy
Bates
Reba McIntyre's acting prowess was so
highly regarded she was actually cast in
the movie Titanic to portray The
Unsinkable Molly Brown she had to
actually ultimately turn down the part
because of scheduling conflicts and the
role was eventually given to Kathy Bates
but I'm sure Reba if she was in the
movie would have knocked it out of the
park when you talk about Reba the
actress we're not the only people that
take note of her of her on-screen Talent
of her on camera Talent James Cameron
actually tapped Reba McIntyre
for the film Titanic she was to play the
role of Molly Brown who went on to be
played by Kathy Bates in the film one of
the highest grossing films of all time
needless to remind anyone of how popular
Titanic was
but she should and could have been there
a scheduling conflict kept her from it
she's one of these she's one of these
these business women who sticks to her
principles of of you stick to a
commitment you don't break a promise and
that's obviously done very well for her
but you can't help but think
what that movie would have been like
with Reba in that role
something to ponder
inner story career Reba has sold over 70
million albums had 64 top 10 hits and
the number one TV sitcom Reba is a
recipient of every country music award
that exists one of her many proud
moments was watching her son Shelby
Blackstock a professional race car
driver compete at NASCAR
I'm very happy that he's racing because
that's his passion uh his father Norma
Blackstock and I have been in the music
business of all our lives and we've just
assumed that was where we were Shelby
was going to follow and
a couple of years ago it didn't seem
like that was going to happen and this
past Thanksgiving I finally just said
what is your passion and he said racing
and I really had no idea and so it's
been it's been incredible we've we've
just um been having a wonderful time
with it if he does one day uh following
his Father's Footsteps to bed in the
management team that's fine but I can I
can understand the excitement of the
race business
Reba McIntyre is a music icon when asked
what is the secret of her success she
replied to succeed in life you need
three things a wishbone a backbone and a
funny bone
it looks like the queen of Nashville's
wishes came true
[Music]
in country music partying is normally
associated with male artists and their
rowdy friends but Miranda Lambert is
changing all of that strapped with a
pink guitar and singing into a pink
microphone Lambert struts across the
stage more like a hardcore rapper than a
country music star Miranda is country
music's Undisputed baddest bad girl
and in addition to this bad girl image
she brought the goods I mean she brought
the American dream you know she fought
her way up to the music industry all she
wanted to do was be a singer but she
wanted to be a singer in her own way and
she did it and her concerts were wild
the raucous the girls are yelling and
screaming and going crazy and I don't
think the girls want to be Miranda
Lambert I think they're going to hang
out with Miranda Lambert and that's the
difference
Lambert's father was a part-time country
performer and songwriter he taught his
little girl how to play the guitar and
write songs the family income however
came from the detective agency owned by
both of her parents which offered
services to abuse women
the fact that Miranda's father was was a
pi or owned a detective agency I think
there's a chance that going back into
her childhood I don't want to sound like
a shrink here or or really analyze who
she is or where she came from but I
think that she might have been exposed
to some different things things that a
lot of these other Country Superstars
weren't exposed to you know it wasn't
all about home cooking and and getting
up and going to church with Mom and Dad
then going out with the grandparents
that evening I think for Miranda the
dinner conversation probably centered
around and focused on the darker side of
life because of the dangers involved in
investigative work Miranda was taught to
shoot a gun as a young girl as a result
she grew up fast registering for a
concealed weapons permit after going out
on the road as a performer Rick Lambert
who also owned and operated a detective
agency
um
he had a gun
showed Miranda how to use it when she
was young she's even a deer hunter today
and it just sort of cements her
reputation as a bad girl with a gun
at the tender age of 21 Lambert released
her first major label single Me and
Charlie talking off the high intensity
kerosene album the album went on to sell
over a million copies and Lambert became
an instant phenomenon when asked about
her hard-hitting Persona Miranda replied
I don't write about angels Jesus happy
days are kids I grew up drinking
cheating and love gone bad
Miranda's appeal really comes from the
fact that she's the complete opposite of
what we see these country music female
superstars to be I mean think back to uh
your Loretta Lynn's and your Tammy
wynettes these were women that were the
quintessential Girl Next Door the
perfect wife the perfect mother that's
what they knew that's what they lived
that's what they sang about where you
fast forward to Modern Times And you
have the modern version of those You
Have Faith Hill and you have uh all of
these women who are just the the the
Picture Perfect Image that we all want
our daughter's growth to be all of a
sudden Here Comes Miranda Lambert
beautiful cute bubbly talented but she's
a bad girl and she's proud of being a
bad girl and it really made everybody
sit up and take notice and go hey wait a
minute this is something really
different
her next album crazy ex-girlfriend was
released on May 9th 2007. Lambert wrote
or co-wrote 10 of the album's 11 Tracks
the single Gunpowder and Lead became her
highest charting single to date the
album solidified Miranda as one of
country's newest Bad Girls
in 2007 Miranda Lambert had a great
success with an album called crazy
ex-girlfriend and uh
that album actually cemented her
reputation as one of countries bad girls
and it's a designation of sort of that
angry temperament that's in her lyrics
it isn't necessarily part of her
demeanor but uh
you know it is one of those things where
she's now created a reputation for
herself and it certainly served her well
well known for obviously writing about
heartbreak and
abusive relationships you know but
people shouldn't feel bad for her it's
pretty clear she comes out up her hand
every time
in 2005 lamber won the Covergirl fresh
face of Country Music Award in 2007 she
received a Grammy nomination for best
female country vocal performance for her
single kerosene in the same year she
also won the top new female vocalist
award at the Academy of Country Music
Awards one year later Miranda won album
of the year at the Academy of Country
Music Awards for Crazy Ex-Girlfriend
Miranda has really achieved great
success in in not only country music but
uh but but the music scene in general
and she's been rewarded for it obviously
I mean she's racked up multiple Awards I
think the reason being because she gives
us everything we want you know we can
safely sit back and really move to her
music we can look at her and say you
know what that's pretty girl that's an
attractive girl her party or her
concerts or parties their fun they're
interactive they're loud it gives us a
chance to really release and the videos
are entertaining so she brings it all
and she puts it right there for you and
she can be the bad girl without you
having to be the bad guy or the bad girl
too
in 2009 Lambert released her third album
Revolution which she co-wrote all but
four of the album's 15 tracks Lambert
and her band performed all the tracks on
the album at the Ryman Auditorium five
days before its release
when Miranda Lambert was younger she'd
attended a Garth Brooks concert and that
lit a fire under her she really realized
that she wanted to be a country singer
she'd had a talent but now she really
wanted to take it a step further
ultimately
she
her career group and she began opening
for huge country Acts George Strait
Keith Urban and Toby Keith among others
and she gained a reputation and has
since
seen her country career flourish that
same year Lambert's boyfriend Blake
Shelton proposed to her after getting
her father's blessing on May 14 2011
wearing her mother's wedding dress
Lambert walked down the aisle and
exchanged vials with Shelton in front of
more than 500 guests
when two of their favorites come
together I mean if you're if you're a
girl between the ages of 15 and 20 right
now you've got one of your favorite
country singers marrying your favorite
heartthrob who's also a country singer
coming together bringing forth this love
story but it's not your typical love
story you know it's the same appeal that
we get in the same same thrill we get
from watching soap operas or prime time
dramas it's a nice romance a hot steamy
Romance
but it also has its darker side it also
has its problems that we get just a
little peek at so we're intrigued we're
enthralled so they're uh they're like
the couple next door that uh that leaves
the drapes open you know we can see in
just enough
to make us want to look
Miranda Lambert has a happy and highly
publicized relationship with Blake
Shelton they are married have a house in
Oklahoma
are very happy together they watch
television together they record together
often sometimes even perform together
but they've found a balance between
their Oklahoma home and the road and
being in Los Angeles recording
television shows and uh and making it
work and making a marriage work along
the way in 2011 to prove she really is
country's baddest bad girl Lambert
brought out of her side project Pistol
Annies Miranda Lambert
released an album along with two other
country artists Ashley Monroe and
Angelina Presley together they form a
trio the Pistol Annies and they released
an album that debuted on the country
charts at number one
which goes to show that everything that
Miranda Lambert touches tends to go
on August 23 2011 the trio debuted their
album which debuted at number one on
Billboard's country chart
this was one of the most exciting new
groups to break out in the country music
genre in years
Trio Pistol Annies consists of Lambert
Ashley Monroe and Angelina Presley their
album Hell on Heels released in 2011 and
debuted number one on the Billboards
country charts you know I'm really I'm
so I'm so thankful for everything that's
happened to me solo and now all I can
think about is my girls and really
developing my band and um and you know
the new album will be just what you
expect it's three country girls singing
about three country girls loves and we
ride everything on our own we did on the
last record in our goal on this next
record is to ride everything just in our
family just the three of us girls again
so I'm really looking forward to it I'm
kind of going to start focusing on that
after this summer tour
in November 2011 Lambert released her
fourth album for the record
she also recorded a song for The Hunger
Games soundtrack called run daddy run
which featured the Pistol Annies
Miranda Lambert is a refreshing country
music star her SASS and fire make her
one of the most Innovative live acts in
the music industry she is truly country
music's most genuine bad girl
Miranda Lambert's fashionist sassy and
wonderful
um you always see her in Black she's
always sparkling and she's always like a
little firecracker when she comes up and
says hello she's got just an abundance
amount of energy and she's just really
friendly too which it's wonderful to see
sometimes you see a Miranda Lambert with
her husband
um like Sheldon and then other times you
don't so on the red carpet you never
know but what you do see when she walks
down the red carpet is just how friendly
she is and she always comes up again
she's like she's your neighbor she's
chatting with you like you've known her
forever and it's a really great
experience when you get a chance to meet
her on the red carpet
I think there's a bit of throwback to
Miranda I think she's uh she takes the
best of the throwback era and mixes it
with the best of today I think that's a
big part of her appeal you know it's
just when you go see Miranda Lambert
you're not thinking hey this is classic
country you're thinking this is
contemporary country
we really um you know are are really
normal people in our everyday life we go
home to a farm in a little bitty town in
Oklahoma and all of this goes away and
um so we're very I could just tell he
felt the way that I did to not looking
in his eyes going holy crap what are we
doing up here you know um we're really
thankful we're humbled we're we're
excited to celebrate it together but I
think he feels the same way I do you
know it's like thank you so much for
letting us win female and male but we
are totally happy and we look at our
awards every day don't get me wrong we
have them all combined in one shelf
which I guess now we got to get our
bigger Shelf
[Music]
foreign
Carrie Marie Underwood was born March 10
1983 to parents Stephen and Carol
Underwood in Muskogee Oklahoma
Carrie was raised in the small rural
town of jakota which inspired the song I
ain't in chakota anymore it includes
references to the local high school team
Wildcats Highway 69 and 40 and the okra
Fest
what can I say I mean
the woman is gorgeous and smart she won
American Idol in the fourth season
and
you know went on to Mega success
she is clearly
you know one of the biggest country
singers of all time she's huge
ironically After High School Underwood
decided to go to college instead of
pursuing a singing career she worked as
a page for Oklahoma State Representative
Bobby fraim competed in beauty pageants
and in 2004 was named Miss NSU runner-up
to make it big in country music you not
only have to have the chops but you have
to have some smarts and Carrie Underwood
has that she graduated from Northeastern
University she was a former page for a
state representative in the state of Cal
of Oklahoma and and she was thrown into
the deep end after having won American
Idol but she came out of it
a stronger person and she has some Savvy
You Can Tell She's parlayed that
experience and that success and made not
only a huge career out of it but now she
is a huge brand and is going on
worldwide tours I expect to see big
things even bigger things from Carrie
Underwood in 2004 Underwood auditioned
for American Idol singing Bonnie raitt's
I can't make you love me in front of
judges Randy Jackson and Simon Cowell
her audition included a chicken
impersonation and the revelation of a
third nipple
however her acapella rendition of a
classic song impressed the panel enough
to give the country girl a golden ticket
to Hollywood
Underwood would go on to become the
American Idol season 4 winner
when I was on the show where it managed
the finale
and we were getting ready for it and all
that stuff and um
somebody comes up to me to explain the
Pyro and they're like okay whatever you
do or whoever wins you have to like get
to the front of the stage immediately
tell the hair and makeup people not to
put hairspray in your hair
thank you
all right
um and they totally did and I told him I
was like no no you can't put hairspray
in my hair I'm gonna like I'm gonna blow
up it's not for the faint of heart
that's for sure you got to get out there
I mean you got to be seen got to be
willing to talk to everybody you know go
to Every audition
um learn from your your mistakes move on
Carrie Underwood is the first country
singer to win American Idol the
television show and uh when she hit
she was a huge sensation her career took
off everybody wanted a piece of her and
she's handled things really really well
um
you know she was a recognizable face
immediately
and she sort of has that you know down
home sweet as apple pie uh Persona and
um the masses eat it up
and
you know
she actually has a great deal of talent
and it comes across and
you know those are the people that
actually make it in this industry it's
not just having the wherewithal and
having some Talent she is very much the
whole package
America and and television Executives
wanted to create Superstars the
executives wanted to create an outlet
and a competition show that America
would sink its teeth into they did it
with American Idol they're doing it with
the voice they're doing it with uh So
You Think You Can Dance they're doing it
with all of these shows and the reason
being is because they wanted to
manufacture Superstars and they did it
Kelly Clarkson but Carrie Underwood is
the one that really stands out she
became a sensation because America had
the opportunity to make her a sensation
how by voting and that makes us feel
like we're a part of her success
Underwood's debut album some hearts was
released in November 2005. it is equal
part soft rock and Country her second
album carnival ride was released in
October 2007. Carrie Underwood well
she's won six Grammys
16 Billboard Music Awards seven
All-American Music Awards and ten awards
from The Academy of Country Music I
think it's pretty fair to say that her
success train is moving right along and
she doesn't plan on getting off at any
time soon
it's really tough to compare people like
Carrie Underwood to anyone else
especially when you're talking about
artists who have jumped over that
country music fence and uh and joined us
over here in the in the world of
mainstream pop and top 40 music but
there's a lot about Carrie Underwood
that we saw not too long ago in Faith
Hill or in Shania Twain you know these
women that young girls wanted to be they
created Anthems for uh for this this new
generation and Carrie Underwood kind of
took that torch and really ran with it
at the 2009 CMA Awards under what was
named Entertainer of the Year making her
the only country female artist in
history to win this award twice and I
think I think she puts a nice
contemporary touch right on top of it
she polished it up and she said hey look
I look like a pop star I look like a
cover girl she is a Covergirl but she's
a country sensation and Men lover women
love her and she's an extremely talented
young woman and I think what what draws
us to her is the fact that she seems
like she's got a great head on her
shoulders she seems like a loving wife
now and we've watched her grown up we
have a lot invested in Carrie Underwood
we've wanted her to succeed from the
first time we saw her and now we're
celebrating in that success each time
she puts out a video each time she puts
out a new hit single each time she comes
to town on tour
in 2010 Kerry co-hosted the CMA Awards
with Brad Paisley for the third year in
a row and was the American Country
Awards top winner what's interesting how
uh how the entertainment industry is has
suddenly paired Carrie Underwood with
Brad Paisley I think Brad might be the
male equivalent to Carrie I think he has
the same kind of following I think he
has the same kind of wholesome appeal
and they have this uh this really nice
Rapport together which we don't see a
lot you know especially in award shows
for example which they've hosted I think
the CMAs three times together now and uh
and and you see hosts crammed together
and if that chemistry isn't there you
can't fake that on television I've been
in situations myself where I've worked
with hosts where it was purely business
and then I've worked with other hosts
where there was a nice friendship off
camera and you can really see the
difference and these two share the same
sense of humor they share the same
respect for country music the same
respect for their fans and that really
shows she was also voted on the people
Magazine's 100 most beautiful people
list for the fourth year in a row in the
that same year Victoria's Secret named
her legs the sexiest legs in Hollywood
American Idol has been a solid vetting
process
um you know if you make it through all
those auditions and all that whole
competition and win the whole thing uh
it's a strong validation
and once Carrie had won American Idol uh
Not only was she immediately
recognizable everywhere it proved that
she really has the talent to make it and
you know she took that momentum and ran
with it and so
you know she had an immediate following
and she's just been able to capitalize
on that ever since and so
you know
she can
we can see her career trajectory even
going up from here after taking the
music industry by storm Carrie decided
to make her acting debut playing
pharmaceutical rep Tiffany on How I Met
Your Mother in 2010.
in 2010 Carrie Underwood branched down
to a role on television she played a
pharmaceutical rep on the television
series How I Met Your Mother
and it was just a quick Cameo appearance
but she proved that she has some acting
Talent as well but it's one of those
things she's not only recognizable and
popular but she's wanted on even the
most popular television shows they gave
her a shot and
she was good on the screen
and I think Carrie Underwood is one of
those performers and I use the word
performer instead of singer because she
comes at us from so many different
angles you know that is just going to
continue to Branch out you know and
everything she does we're really
entertained by and good entertainment is
so hard to come by these days when she
was on How I Met Your Mother for example
she was great small part but she fitted
perfectly you know and and like I said
we want Carrie Underwood to succeed in
whatever she does
winning the fourth season of the world's
biggest talent show Carrie Underwood a
shy singer with a goofy sense of humor
hasn't looked back since selling 11
million albums
when Carrie Underwood was on American
Idol Simon Cowell was still one of the
judges
and Simon is a tough critic there's no
question about that he's had that
reputation
but he knows when someone has
the talent to make it and he saw that in
Carrie Underwood and
and now obviously
you know the masses have seen that
Talent come through too he's a strong
critic but he's got a good eye for
talent and
and Kerry is very much that she's
talented Faith Hill Reba McIntyre
Miranda Lambert Carrie Underwood and
Taylor Swift all have talent and the
will to succeed in common they've each
overcame obstacles that got in the way
of their country's dreams they found
their voice wrote their songs and
entertained their fans around the world
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign